روسيا تدمر معقلين لاوكرانيا في زابوريا
وتسريبات جديده تكشف موافقه صربيا على
تصليحه
مبدا الصين واحده سيدفع تايوان الى وضع
خطير في نهايه المطاف
يؤكد انه لن ينسحب من سباق الرئاسه ويقول
ان بايدن لا يستطيع الترشح
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير واهلا بكم اعلنت وكاله
سبوتنيكا الروسيه ان القوات العسكريه
لموسكو دمرت نقطتين استراتيجيتين لجيشكيف
في زابوريا عند منطقتي
واسفر دمارهما عن مقتل ما يصل الى عشره
اشخاص من صفوف الاوكرانيين بينهم ثلاثه
ينتمون الى فريق النيران المتحركه وبحسب
سبوتنك اطلقت القوات الاوكرانيه النارستا
على اراضي جمهوريه دونيت كالشعبيه خلال
الساعات 24 الماضيه حيث تم اطلاقه 123
قذيفه وفي الاتجاه الجنوبي منذ نيتك تمكنت
روسيا من اسقاط صواريخ من نوع هاي مارس
باستخدام انظمه صواريخ اس اس 300
قبل ذلك اعلن المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه
ان قوات فاجنر تمكنت من التقدم في وسط
مدينه باقمود واضاف ان فاجنر تدفع القوات
الاوكرانيه نحو الجزء الغربي للمدينه
نظريه
في اتجاه دونتسك جهود القتال الرئيسيه في
منطقه
الوحدات الهجوميه التابعه لفاجنر القتال
للاستيلاء على مناطق من الجزء الاوسط
منوفسكي ودفع العدو الى الضواحي الغربيه
في المنطقه
رغم ان صربيا هي الدوله الاوروبيه الوحيده
التي رفضت معاقبه روسيا الاجتياحها
اوكرانيا افادت وثيقه سريه لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان صربيا وافقت على ارسال
الاسلحه الى كيف او قد زودتها بالفعل
بينما رفضت توفير تدريب للقوات الاوكرانيه
وبحسب الوثيقه وهي عباره عن ملخص لردود
الحكومات الاوروبيه لطلبات اوكرانيا
الخاصه بالتدريب والمساعده العسكريه بحسب
الوثيقه يوجد لدى صربيا الاراده السياسيه
والقدره العسكريه على توفير الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا مستقبلا
ونشرت صحيفه
البريطانيه معلومات استقتها من وثائق
امريكيه مسربه تتحدث عن العجز العسكري
لاوكرانيا وتطرقت الوثيقه الى الفشل
الاوكراني الامريكي في تشكيل 12 لواء
لاطلاق هجوم مضاد وقال دبلوماسي اوروبي
للغورديين ان امريكا شككت دائما في فعاليه
اوكرانيا العسكريه كما ان الصحيفه
البريطانيه وجدت في وثيقه من الوثائق ان
الرئيس وزراء المجر فيكتور اوربن يعتبر
امريكا من اكبر ثلاثه خصوم لحزبه كما ان
اوربن يخشى تدخل امريكيا في انتخابات
بلاده
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان بلاده ستواصل
التحقيق في التسريب لوثائق سريه حتى تعرف
المصدر وشدد اوستن خلال مؤتمر صحفي على ان
واشنطن تتعامل مع قضيه الوثائق المسربه
بشكل جدي مشيرا الى انه يتواصل مع كبار
القاده العسكريين يوميا للرد على تسريب
الوثائق واوضح وزير الدفاع الامريكي وثائق
البانتاغون يعود تاريخها الى الفتره من
نهايه فبراير وحتى الاول من مارس
من جهته يعتبر مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه
ان تسريب الوثائق السريه شيء مؤسف للغايه
وقال مدير السي اي اي ان روسيا تخاطر بان
تصبح مستعمره اقتصاديه للصين بمرور الوقت
[موسيقى]
المشكله فيما ذكرته ان التسريب الوثائق
السريه مؤسف للغايه وانت تعلم هذا امر
تاخذ الاداره الامريكيه على محمل الجد
اطلق البنتاجون ووزاره العدل الان تحقيقا
مكثفا للوصول الى حقيقه الامر ليس هناك
الكثير الذي يمكنني اضافته في هذه المرحله
مع استمرار هذا التحقيق
اذا نظرت حقيقه الى روسيا فانها اصبحت
تعتمد اكثر فاكثر على الصين وفي بعض
النواحي تخاطر بان تصبح مستعمره اقتصاديه
للصين مع مرور الوقت
هذا واكد مسؤول امريكي في تصريحات لشبكات
سي ان ان تحقيق في تسريب الوثائق قد
يستغرق اشهرا واوضح المسؤول الامريكي ان
المعلومات السريه يتم تداولها عبر الاف
الموظفين في البنساجون الذين لهم صلاحيه
الاطلاع عليها مشددا على ان هذا الامر
سيتم تعديله
تسريبات من اروقه البنتاجون الى العالم
كشفت عمه تخططه امريكا كما كشفت اختراق
احدى عشر دوله بدءا من الصين الى هايتي في
هذه الوثيقه ما يدل على ان الصين تحت
المجهر تتجسس امريكا على عدوتها اللدود
فهنا وثائق تضمنت تحليلا للمخاطر الصينيه
واسعه النطاق واستعداد بكين لارسال
مساعدات فتاكه الى روسيا وتفاصيل اختبار
تجريبي لصاروخ النووي يفوق سرعه الصوت
تسريبات كشفت ايضا ان امريكا تمارس ضغوطا
على كوريا الجنوبيه في حثها لارسال
مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا في وقت تتخوف
سول من غضب موسكو وثيقه اخرى كشفت مساعي
اسرائيل لتزويد اوكرانيا بنظام دفاع جوي
سبايدر سام اضافه الى صواريخ جافل المضاده
للدروع بينما يتضح هنا ان روسيا ستزود
ايران بطائرات سوخوي 35 ونظام دفاع جوي
وقدرات صاروخيه الوثيقه عرجت ايضا على قلق
اسرائيل الشديد من التقارب العسكري بين
روسيا وايران مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه طالتها
نار التسريبات ايضا فضحت احدى الوثائق
مخططه فاجنر للسفر الى هايتي والتعاون
رسميا مع عصابات مسلحه متهمه بقضايا قتل
واختطاف مسلسل التسريبات لا تزال تحليلاته
مستمره عالميا ما يضع الولايات المتحده
امام حرج سياسي وعسكري قد يغير الحسابات
مستقبلا غذاء السالم العربيه
اعلنت روسيا انها اجرت تجربه ناجحه لاطلاق
صاروخ باليستي متقدم عابر للقارات وبحسب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اطلق الصاروخ
البالستي بنجاح من نظام صاروخي ارضي متحرك
من موقع التجارب في كابوشتينيار الهدف من
التجربه هو اختبار معدات قتاليه متطوره
لصواريخ الماليستيه عبره للقارات وذلك وفق
الدفاع الروسيه ياتي هذا بعد تحذيرات
مبطنه اطلقها الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوزن
بانه قد يستخدم اسلحه نوويه هناك اذا
تعرضت بلاده الى الخطر
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن اربعه مصادر ان
الصين تخطط لفرد منطقه حظر طيران في شمال
تايوان من السادس عشر الى الثامن عشر من
ابريل الجاري وقالت المصادر ان الحضره
سيعطل معلومات الطيران في المنطقه وان سبب
فرض هذه القيود غير واضح حتى الان
قبل ذلك قالت المتحدثه باسم مكتب شؤون
تايوان الصيني ان تواطؤ الحزب الديمقراطي
التقدمي التايواني مع قوى خارجيه مستفزه
للاستقلال هو اكبر تحدي للسلام والامن في
مضيق تايوان المتحدثه حذرت من ان مواصله
تحدي مبدا الصين الواحده سيضع تايوان في
وضع خطير من الحرب في نهايه المطاف
من جانبها اشارت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
الى ان اربعه عشره طائره تابعه للقوات
الجويه الصينيه عبرت خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه خط المنتصف عند مضيق تايوان
والذي يعتبر فاصلا غير رسمي بين الجانبين
في حين رصدت وزاره الدفاع 35 طائره وثماني
سفن صينيه حول الجزيره
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع
كوريا الشماليه تتعهد بالبدء في مشاريع
فضائيه نشطه واصطم مخاوف من اطلاقها قمر
صناعي للتجسس
احييكم من جديد اعلنت كوريا الشماليه عن
تعهدها بمتابعه تطوير المشاريع الفضائيه
بمناسبه اليوم العالمي الانطلاقي اول رحله
بشريه الى الفضاء واصطم مخاوف من اطلاقها
المحتمل لقمر صناعي هدفه التجسس العسكري
كوريا الشماليه اعلنت ايضا استعدادها
الثابت لتحويل نفسها الى قوه فضائيه
عالميه مؤكده انها تحرز تقدما متتاليا في
تطوير مشاريع الفضاء وفق معاهده الفضاء
الخارجي
اعلن الجيش الهندي اين انا حادثه اطلاق
نار وقع في ساعه مبكره من اليوم الاربعاء
في محطه باثندا العسكريه في ولايه البنجاب
الحدوديه شمال الهند واسفر عن مقتل اربعه
اشخاص بحسب الجيش عمليه البحث الجاريه وتم
اغلاق المنطقه ووفقا مصدر في وزاره الدفاع
لرويترز فان عددا غير معلوم من مطلق النار
ما زالوا طلقاء في المحطه العسكريه
اكد المجلس العسكري في ميانمار شن غاره
جويه على قريه في وسط البلاد اودت بحياه
نحو 100 شخص بحسب تقارير محليه وقال
المتحدث باسم المجلس العسكري ان القصف
استهدف جماعه مناهضه وصفها بالارهابيه كما
اقر بسقوط ضحايا مدنيين وقال عضو في قوات
الدفاع الشعبي في ميانمار ان طائرات
مقاتله قصفت حفل افتتاح لمكتبها المحلي
في لقائه مع قناه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه اكد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
عمق الروابط التي تربط الولايات المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وقال ان
القياده السعوديه عظيمه وتريد مساعدتنا
واضافت ترامب ان مشكله الولايات المتحده
لا تكمن في روسيا ولكن في الراديكيليين
داخل امريكا وعن الانسحاب من افغانستان
اضافت ترامب ان الجنرال ميلي قال انه من
الارخص تركوا المعدات خلفنا في افغانستان
معتبرا ان رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
الجنرال مارك مالي عار على البلاد
قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
فان الموظفين كانوا يبكون اثناء محاكمته
ترام تعهد بان لا ينسحب مطلقا من سباق
الانتخابات المقبله مؤكدا ان هذا ليس من
طبيعته لكنه اعرب عن اعتقاده بان بايدن لا
يستطيع الترشح الانتخابات الرئاسه المقبله
لقد شاهدته مثلك تماما واعتقد انه من غير
لائق بالنسبه لي ان اقول ذلك ولكن لا ارى
كيف يمكن ذلك هناك شيء خاطئ لقد رايت
اجابته اليوم على التلفاز حول امكانيه
ترشحه ولن تجد سؤالا اسهل من ذلك اما
اجابه بايدن فكانت مطوله عن اشياء اخرى
اعتقد انه لا يستطيع الترشح
وصل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى بلفاست
في ايرلندا الشماليه وسيلقي بايدن الذي
كان في استقباله رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك سيلقي خطابا الاربعاء في جامعه
في بلفاست يركز فيه على اتفاق السلام
التاريخي الموقع قبل 25 عاما قبل ان يتوجه
الى جمهوريه ايرلندا حيث سيزور العاصمه
دوبلن ومقاطعات لاوت ومايو التي يتحذر
منها اجداده
قالت صحيفه بولاتيكو الامريكيه ان تيارا
داخل الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي يتبنى القوه
لمواجهه تهريب المخدرات من المكسيك وذكرت
الصحيفه ان عددا متزايدا من الجمهوريين
البارزين يؤيدون ضرب مواقع المافيا
المكسيكيه لحل ازمه مخدر الفنتانيلين
الولايات المتحده تغرق بالمخدرات والمكسيك
في دائره الاتهام والسبب مخدر الفنتونويل
المخدر الفتاك دفع باعضاء من الحزب
الجمهوري الى اقتراح ادراج مافيات
المخدرات المكسيكيه على قوائم الارهاب او
حتى قصفها بالصواريخ دونالد ترامب الرئيس
السابق ناقش ارسال قوات خاصه واستخدام
الحرب الالكترونيه لاستهداف قاده المافيا
اذا اعيد انتخابه ليست المره الاولى التي
يتحدث فيها ترامب عن ذلك ففي ولايته طلب
من وزير الدفاع انذاك موك اسبر عام 2020
اطلاق صواريخ على المكسيك لتدمير مختبرات
تصنيع المخدرات وفقا ما ذكره في مذكراته
لكن يبدو ان هذا التوجه يروق اخرين ثم
نواب جمهوري يؤيدون استخدام القوه
العسكريه ضد الكارتيلات المكسيكيه
وتقنيدها ايضا استهداف المافيات حتى بدون
اذن المكسيك تلك اتهامات ودعوات ترفضها
الاخيره
رفض وصفه السيناتور الجمهوري لينز جرايم
بحاله انكار
شركائنا في المكسيك في حاله انكار تامه
رئيس المكسيكي ينكر ان بلاده ملاذ امن
لعصابات المخدرات التي تدير مناطق في
المكسيك ويقول ان الامر ليس صحيحا ويلومنا
على ازمه الفينتنايل الرئيس المكسيكي نفى
انتاج في بلاده فيما يؤكد مسؤولون
امريكيون عكس ذلك لا بل وينتج باستخدام
مواد كيميائيه مصدرها الصين
قال مالك شركه تويتر ايلين ماسك ان المنصه
ستزيل في العشرين من ابريل علامات التحقق
الزرقاء لمن لا يدفع الاشتراك واعلنت
الشركه في وقت سابق ان الاشتراك في الخدمه
سيكلف 8 دولارات شهريا للمستخدمين الذين
يشتركون عبر الموقع و11 دولار شهريا
لاولئك الذين يشتركون عبر
وكجزء من نظام التحقق الجديد سيقدم تويتر
علامات ذهبيه للشركات ورماديه للكيانات
الحكوميه والمؤسسات الاخرى وزرقاء للافراد
سواء كانوا من المشاهير ام لا
يواصل مسلسل منه ولدنا في الجزء الثاني
كسبه ثقه المشاهد السعودي والخليجي على حد
سواء اتصدرت مشاهدات المسلسل والنقاشات
حول قصته تصدرت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
المزيد في فقره كواليس مع سهى الوعل
واعداد ايام القاسم
[موسيقى]
التي لا تشبه كل القصص
مرحبا من رمضان الماضي استطاع مسلسل منه
ولدنا انه يصنع لنفسه قاعده جماهيريه
كبيره حيث تقدم جيل تلفزيوني جديد من نجوم
الكوميديا الشباب الجزء الجديد جاء من
زاويه مختلفه فبعد ما كانت القصه تدور فقط
في جزء الاول عن الشابين اتبدل وقت
الولاده وما ترتب على ذلك
ركز الجزء الجديد على امور اخرى كطموحات
كل منهما وكيف دمرت احداهما الاخرى
بيكون في شيء اصعب يعني او انه لازم احنا
نصير احسن او هم يصيرون احسن انا احس كل
فريق او كل عمل له جوا وكل ناس او يعني كل
ناس لهم لهم الاشياء اللي يحبونها
بعمل يعني اتجه الى منحنى مختلف تماما عن
الجزء الاول وبيكون واضح بالنسبه للمشاهد
الجزء الاول ممكن كان التركيز اكثر شيء
على الكوميديا بينما الجزء الثاني لا تفرع
وراح اتجاه النصر الى عده امور ولكن ما
تخلو من الكوميديه الكوميديا موجوده ولكن
المستوى الدرامي اصبح اكثر من الكوميدين
ولكن بطريقه لطيفه وخفيفه على المشاهده
المسلسل بحسب استطاع انه يحتل المركز
الرابع في السعوديه من ناحيه ارقام
المشاهده اسهم في ذلك بحسب راي النقاد
توقيت عرضه مباشره بعد مسلسل طاش ما طاش
في الفتره الذهبيه هو نجاح الموسم الاول
حملنا مسؤوليه كبيره كان نجاح كبير وعظيم
والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني
وصلنا فيه لمناطق كنا حابينه وصلنا لها
فالجزء هذا احنا في مسؤوليه علينا لازم
نكون نقدم افضل
من الجزء الاول فالجزء الثاني في مفاجات
حلوه في احداث جميله في تنوع شخصيات تنوع
احداث جميله بصراحه عائله وحده ولا قاعد
نقدمها جدا جميل الحمد لله تغير وتركتر
بيني كريان وبين الاستاذ محمد كان جميل
جدا ليش للريان الموسم الاول كان قاسي
معها تماما الين صار الدرس اللي هو رجع
العالم الفقر ثم رجع المكان الحقيقي
الان مع بعض التغريدات من هنا وهناك حول
العالم
[موسيقى]
احنا حبيناك عشانك انت
انا حبيتك عشانك انت فلا تغير نفسك عشان
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
روسيا تدمر معقلين لاوكرانيا وتسريبات
جديده تكشف موافقه صربيه على تصليح كييف
بكينتو حذره من ان تحدي مبدا الصين واحده
سيدفع تايوان الى وضع خطير في نهايه
المطاف
يؤكد انه لن ينسحب من سباق الرئاسه ويقول
ان بايدن لا يستطيع الترشح
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات